ماسكه يحاول وتحديثها التكنولوجيا الخاصه
ببرنامج القياده الذي سيغير العالم على حد
قوله نهجوا الشركات سيساعد على التقليل او
وقف الوفيات الناجمه عن الاخطاء البشريه
على الطرقات غير ان هذا حتى اللحظه ليس
دقيقه
هناك حوادث وفايات وشكاوي المركبه تتوقف
ومبكرا جدا عند الاقتراب من علامه التوقف
وتحاول السير على طرقات المزدحمه دون
الالتفات للاشارات وتارجح ايضا مشكله وهذا
احد المقاطع المصوره التي يقول خبراء انها
مطلقه جدا تظهر كيف يتدخل السائق السيطره
على النظام الالي وضبطي مسار السياره اكثر
من مره
رغم بقى لك يصف ماسك ان تخلي عن هذه
التكنولوجيا سيكون خطا اخلاقيا والسؤال هل
يتخلى ماسك عن التكنولوجيا ربما لان يتخلى
وانما قد يجبره القضاء فتسلى تواجه حاليا
تحقيقا جنائيا في الولايات المتحده بشان
هذه المزاعم تحقيقات بدات العام الماضي
بحسب رويترز وتحقيق اخر تواجه تسلا في
الصين تبقى صوره الحادث الاخير فيها
الاكثر قسوه وتحقيقات بكين ايضا لم تنتهي
بعد
[موسيقى]
اليوم